Okay Ladies and gentlemen,
good morning.
I think things are going to work better today.
I'm optimistic about the uh,
audio equipment and about our slide material and things such as that.
All cell phones off and we will begin,
don't forget section start tonight at seven o'clock and there's another set it
at eight o'clock and then Friday afternoon at one 30 and Monday morning you've
got that all online for you.
You do your work product and you bring it to sections and handed into your ta in
section each time.
So,
uh,
that's the way this works.
I'll be sending you a global email,
uh,
bringing you up to date with some other things later on this afternoon.
Okay.
So today we actually,
before I get to the,
any questions from you?
Yeah.
Is there stuff,
stuff to do for section tonight?
Yes.
Uh,
but only the stuff that was assigned,
the listing exercises that were assigned early on,
it's just one nine through 11,
which you've probably had done for days now.
So you just bring that material handed in.
Others will be assigned tonight.
This is shopping period.
We're started sifting through things.
And then we'll get rolling.
Gentlemen here.
Can I turn on my microphone?
Very good idea.
And matter of fact,
I think I'm,
I'm actually missing a microphone and it was not put on on here.
So what do I do with this?
Okay.
Uh,
so I gentlemen,
you will have to come and do this as you would like to have it done.
Uh,
okay.
Put this on your,
on your tag.
Let's turn to span of time.
Okay,
here we go.
Sorry.
Um,
today we're going to come to what I would call the nitty gritty of the course.
We're no longer having introductory material,
but we're going to jump into the question of musical notation and we're going to
be dealing with things such at half notes,
quarter notes,
things like that.
Uh,
but before we do this,
I'd like to say a couple of words about musical notation because it sort of
affects how we deal with music,
how we treat music.
Seems to me that there's a very large reverberation in here.
Now,
is that the case?
Does it sound like it's reverberating to,
you know,
sounds okay to you?
Alright.
Uh,
musical notation.
Musical notation is a particularly Western phenomenon.
When you stop and think about it,
only we in the west and by West what I mean,
the United States and Canada and western Europe and Russia,
parts of South America only.
We use musical notation and we use it principally for our,
uh,
high art music.
That's not to say that the Chinese don't have,
uh,
an esoteric form of music notation that the Indians do not have an esoteric form
of musical notation.
They do,
but it doesn't intersect quite as intensely as musical notation does in western
cultures.
Most cultures around the world,
if you stop and think about it,
don't use musical notation.
But we do here with our art music and that has two advantages.
Let's talk about the advantages first one.
It allows the composer to specify rather precisely what he or she wants to sort
of write things out in the form of musical details.
So as a result,
the creator in this western art form takes on greater importance than the
Creator in other cultures where the composers,
so to speak,
is more or less anonymous and perhaps synonymous with the group as a whole.
So again,
the process of notation allows the composer here to a loom larger.
And secondly,
this is another advantage of notation.
It allows us to preserve the work of art.
We can kind of freeze dry this thing and store it and then bring it back to life
more or less exactly as the composer had attended.
But this,
if you stop and think about it,
um,
takes the traditional balance of things and throws it out of proportion in our
art.
Music are symphonies concertos,
uh,
genres of this sort.
The performer isn't actually much less important.
He's sort of in there.
Let's think of this as architect and carpenter,
the great architect,
the thinker is the composer and the performer.
The violinists gets this piece of,
gets this blueprint or black print in the case of musical notation and as
expected simply to replicate the black print.
Well,
that's very different than what happens in other kinds of music,
other kinds of music.
Let's talk about pop music for a second.
A Jazz Rock,
hip hop blues,
that kind of thing.
You go over to the toads,
you see the band come out in,
the first thing they do is plunk this in front of them.
No,
that'd be ridiculous.
How many of you I was with walking with a student over to my office after
lecture the other day to get some material to them.
Uh,
how many of you play in a rock band or have ever played in a rock band?
Okay.
And number of view,
a young lady out there.
Did you use musical notation now?
Uh,
that,
that'd be kind of silly,
right?
It's okay.
So how is it done?
Well,
it's all done orally and we'll talk a little bit more about that as we,
as we go along.
Uh,
so the composer and the West is very important.
More important than the composer in other cultures,
other cultures don't use this type of notation.
Here's a thought for you.
Musical notation was the first graph in western culture.
How could that be?
You say how that be?
Well,
if you go back to the formation of,
of musical notation from the ninth to the 12th centuries,
we see that very early on these two dimensions of music,
the two axes of music that we talked about before,
Pich,
vertically and duration,
horizontally are in place.
And we have these sort of spots in this grid.
So musical notation,
first grid pattern in western culture.
But it does lock us in in interesting ways that we mean you perhaps have never
have never,
uh,
considered particularly composed compared to how music is made in other
cultures.
Let's see how some music is made and,
and other cultures.
We're going to play here now as our first excerpt.
I'm an odd Hahn.
And,
uh,
what this is,
is the Islamic Call to worship,
uh,
which is sung across the world thousands of times every day.
And as we listened to this,
I want you to think about the vocal production here and how,
what's interesting or all the vocal nuances.
So let's listen to just a bit of this please.
No Fun.
Ah,
ah,
uh,
how are ya?
Ah,
yeah.
Hi y'all.
Ah,
Oh,
ah,
let's stop there.
Fascinating.
What a wonderful sound.
But the beauty of it is all between what we would call the notes.
We would specify a precise frequency here.
Another one up here.
But what that gentleman was singing,
it was all the stuff in between that made it very beautiful and there's no way
in God's earth that we could locate that through the western system of musical
notation.
Let's take another example.
We're going to go to the realm of Western jazz here.
I'm going to pick on chuck.
Man,
Joni.
Anybody ever heard of Chuck Mangione?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Brian or tech guy has,
he's,
he's an older fellow.
He's sort of my age.
Uh,
and um,
the reason I mentioned chuck man is that years ago I went to school with him.
He was a couple of classes ahead of me at the Eastman School of music.
I was a fledgling pianist.
He was a very good trumpeter.
And deedee was winning grammys when he was in his twenties and he's been
recording sort of esoteric and sometimes more pop jazz.
They're after now.
Uh,
you can go to a man,
Joanie,
chuck concert.
He will sometimes play the Shubert theater there and you'll have two hours of
spectacular,
uh,
jazz.
Uh,
but what you won't see again is any sort of music in front of them.
So how do these musicians generate two hours of music with,
with no,
with no music in front of them?
Does this mean he doesn't read music?
Of course not.
You can't get through these conservatories like Eastman or Juilliard or Curtis
without being introduced to an intense regimen of musical notation.
But it sort of,
otherwise we'd get in the way of the music.
So let's listen to a track here,
a Sax Solo,
and I'm going to try to keep,
make some sense out of this because it gets more and more complex by following
the electric base underneath the let you listen to an old tape.
I used to go to bars and Rochester and listen to this guy and tape his stuff.
So here's,
here's Chuck Mangione with his saxophonist and a saxophone sort of cadenza
almost.
It's a wild riff for saxophone.
Okay?
Okay.
Gives you an idea.
How in the world would you ever notate that you to produce this prescriptive
document that anybody else could follow was all improvisitory.
They tried to notate it again and would take all the spirit out,
all the heart out of the music.
Well,
how do they do that though?
How did these performers plays such a long spans of music without any notation?
Is it all memorized?
Well,
it's not memorize as we think.
And you may have had music lessons along the way and your teacher and your
mother said,
go memorize your piece.
It's not memorized like that.
There are certain basic patterns that they have.
They might have a,
let's say for that sort of music,
they've say,
all right,
we're now going to have a 32 bars solo,
where be in the key of e flat.
We're gonna work through a one six,
four,
five one core progression.
Uh,
as we'll see when we come back to it,
we'll sit on the,
the dominant Chord for eight beats and all I chuck will look over and everybody
else will come back in the end of Chris's Solo.
It would be that kind of thing.
Kind of head charge,
general plans and within that general plan,
a lot of freedom of expression.
So having said that,
having said that about musical notations,
something about a cautionary tale about musical notation,
we should think about how it affects the way we compose music in the West and
how we perform music in the west.
When you go to a concert of classical music and the music is playing and you
start to talk,
what happens?
Somebody will go,
right,
we go to these concerts and we have to be so quiet.
Why do we have to be quiet?
That doesn't sound like much fun.
It's because we had these performers up there that are reading this blueprint
and everyone is listening basically to see how accurately they can reproduce
revivify this artistic artifact.
So that's sort of what's going on.
But it really does affect how we behave.
Even in a concert.
No.
If you go to other cultures of,
and they are engaged in their own classical,
not just popular but classical music,
Indonesian Gamelan music for example,
the audience will be there swaying back and forth,
uh,
clapping,
applauding with the performance for particularly good solo.
The same thing with Indian sitar music,
that classical tradition,
oddly,
it's much more like going to a jazz concert.
You know,
where the audience is sitting.
Maybe round tables or something like that and encouraging and interacting with
the,
with the performers.
But again,
in those cultures,
no notation notation,
everybody just sits there sort of Moma fine waiting for this great work of art
to come back to life.
It's an interesting thing.
Uh,
and isn't a sort of typical of us in the West to take something music,
which is expression and feeling and motion and movement and a response to sound
and turn it in to a complex patterns,
complex patterns that can be sort of visualized and rearranged and analyzed.
And nowadays even digitalized,
what we've done is take this spontaneous response to the creation of sound and
bodily movement with sound and sort of a re replaced it.
We've replaced the ear and they'd be the heart,
the ear,
and the body with the eye and the mind.
It's a much more visual.
It's a much more analytical type of approach to music and it has its pros and
cons.
We get great Mahler's symphonies,
yet we have everybody sitting there rock still at these concerts.
Okay.
Having said that,
and I guess pointing out the the advantages and disadvantages of notation,
let's plunge in then to a discussion.
It put on the board up here.
The following,
we're going to review this.
It's simply material found on page 15 of your textbook,
but let's review it.
We say this is a beginning course,
so we assume,
uh,
no previous knowledge.
If you've read through that material and you should have read through it by now,
you know that we have a value in music that's called the whole note.
What the whole note is,
what all these symbols are are simply representations of duration.
So we have a symbolic language here that's going to represent the horizontal
axis,
the axis of of duration.
And this whole node obviously can be subdivided into two half notes and each of
the half notes into two quarter,
no teacher,
the quarter notes into two eighth notes and so on.
So these are symbols telling us how long a particular frequency is to endure.
Similarly,
justice,
we have symbols for the presence of sound and its length.
We have symbols that represent the absence of sound.
We call those,
of course.
What?
Rest.
Okay,
so arresting over here,
we're not making any music.
So we have the notes in their values and the,
and the rest.
Notice that they're all pretty much um,
uh,
Dupo in their divisions.
Now here's a question for you all.
Dupal divisions.
How do we make,
how do we get triple arrangements in music?
How do we do that?
Well,
we take our basic note and what do we do to it?
I've been,
I'm sure some of you noted that.
How can we get a half note that actually equals now three quarter notes?
What did we do gentlemen here?
At a dot.
What does that do to this value specifically in terms of ratios,
it adds,
okay,
that's 50% or a half to that and that means instead of two quarter notes that we
now have three and we can do the same thing to any one of these other values
here and that's how we get our triple relationships.
Okay,
so those are the basic note values normally with a Dupal division,
but we can super impose triple by using a doc and the absence of sound.
Now let's talk for a moment about the idea of pulse in music and the beat in the
music and rhythms in music.
We all know that there is this thing in music called beat and to the extent that
popular music is more interesting and that you,
everybody likes it and go dance to it just because it's really foregrounding
beat and rhythm in an important way that classical music does not.
So I've put a,
this idea of the beat up on the board here.
It's really just a pulse.
It's very much likely human pulse.
This is the,
the pulse of music and music theorists ever since the late 15th century from
Kenya's Ghafoori us.
We could go all the way back to him if said that the pulse and music is
basically at the same tempo as the human pulse,
which comes out to be about,
oh,
we'll say 72 beats if you will,
pulses per,
uh,
per minute.
So we have this pulse and it's just kind of out there streaming be uh,
uh,
but we don't like undifferentiated disorganized material in the west.
Our Psyche says we've got to bring rational organization to this.
Ever think about this.
Why do we have this periodicity when you take history courses,
why do we have the renaissance,
the baroque period,
the classical period,
uh,
the romantic period and so on.
We have it in music.
You have in,
in history,
we have it in the fine arts.
Why do we have it?
It's simply a convention established after the fact that allows us to organize
material in ways that we can grapple with it.
The ways that we can understand it.
So in music,
what has happened is that we have organized this steady stream of beats in ways
that we can understand it.
We organize and we s we subdivide these into units of two for example,
groups of two like this or we have an undifferentiated stream like this.
I am convinced even though I'm sure that the Toyota Motor Company didn't
organize it this way,
I am convinced that on my automobile when I do not plug in my safety belt,
uh,
that there is a bell ringing.
Ding,
ding,
Ding Dane Dane.
I don't think they were thinking of that in terms of triple meter here.
I think they were just a succession of deans,
but I'm hearing it.
My mind wants to hear this organization.
So there's another organization here of units of three.
As you may know,
there's yet another organization where we could group this in units of four but
for all intents and purposes there are a few nuances to it for is simply a
multiplication of two.
So in our course we are only going to have two types,
two types of meters.
These organizations taking the beat and organizing it into groups is called
super imposing meter on the music.
Then we want to indicate that meter to the performer.
It's a way to tell the performer how this music is to be executed.
So what do we do?
Well in music,
the most basic symbol for the beat is the quarter note.
The quarter note usually carries the beat.
Okay,
so here we have a series of groups of two quarter knows we have the convention
of music of writing this symbol indicating the beat carrying unit of four.
So I'm writing a four underneath each of these.
Then I look up here and I say,
well,
up in this Dupo pattern,
I have two of these quarter notes.
So I'm going to write a two out there that tells the performer that the quarter
note is carrying the B.
Think of the,
and you see according to note,
that's a beat and that there'll be two in each of your units.
These units we call bars or measures,
and just to finish this off,
down here,
we would have three quarter notes of course in this particular arrangement.
Okay.
Now ultimately what happens with this is that we begin to take this stream and
organize it into different pattern.
I could go dada the dog dot.
Um,
something like this.
And we would call that a rhythm,
super imposing longs and shorts,
different patterns,
patterns that oftentimes repeat the dividing up of this stream into different
patterns.
Often repeating of longs and shorts is super imposing,
super imposing rhythm over top of this basic beat,
which is organized in terms of these meters.
So there questions about that.
That seems straightforward enough.
Now,
as you may know,
you've probably seen some of you may have played clarinet in high school band or
something like that.
A neither here nor there if you did or did not.
But uh,
you may know that there are other meters out there.
These things called six eight.
I was thinking this morning bomb,
bt DDP,
the bomb BP,
BP team,
the up,
up,
up at the fuck did the four,
five,
six,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six month.
Well that's a beat is basically a duplo meter with a triple subdivision,
but we're not getting into triple subdivisions here in our course.
The beat is always going to be a divided to the extent that is divided.
Always going to be divided into two.
We have only so called simple meters rather than compound meters and want to
learn about compound meters,
go take music to 10 and become a music major.
That's a kind of thing that they get into,
but we're not doing that here.
We're interested only really in the two things.
One,
can you differentiate between Dupal and triple meter and two,
can you recognize some very basic with Mick patterns and we'll be doing some of
that today.
Questions again?
Okay.
Let's,
uh,
then proceed.
Uh,
used to have some glasses,
but that's,
that's okay.
Uh,
I'll just,
Oh,
here they are.
Okay.
Let me play some music at the piano.
This is bulldog.
Isn't this the Yale fight song?
Who wrote this?
Anybody know?
You know,
you've probably heard it a zillion times at football games.
It's a great,
what a wonderful,
yeah.
Well.
Yeah,
it was so lucky to have this as a,
uh,
so yes,
I think I hear somebody out there,
Cole Porter who was Cole Porter as I van for my music here.
Ah,
Oui.
Have loss.
Who was Cole Porter?
He was a Yale graduate class of,
of 1914.
Uh,
and unfortunately I seem to have misplaced,
I like and generate a little bit of it here.
Oh,
okay.
Is it sort of trying to remember the first page of missing music diff.
So is this an Dupo meter or triple meter?
What do you think and how do we find out?
Tap your foot.
Did we find any music?
Oh,
I think enlightenment.
Enlightenment from Linda.
Hmm.
What's the key here?
What do you listen to?
How many think it's in Dupo meter?
Raise your hand.
How many think it's in triple meter?
Okay.
Almost everybody thinks it's in Dupal meter.
And that's correct.
And we worked through this just a little bit once before.
What is it that tells us that it's in Dupal meter?
It's the base
because it's more organizing itself.
Very strongly.
DUPO patterns.
There's one other interesting thing in here.
This would be,
well,
let,
let's,
let's think through that one in one additional way.
And that is notice that in dupont media we have a strong beat,
right?
Strong,
strong,
we are strong,
we draw,
we draw weak in that sense.
Or if we have triple,
it would be strong,
weak,
strong,
weak.
It would be too weak beach or to unstressed beats between each strong bid.
We could do this
and we'd have the waltz of the bulldog.
It'd be pretty cool to see actually.
So there I'm simply taking the Cole porter piece and throwing in an extra beat
in each measure,
an unstressed beat in each measure.
And it works out pretty well.
Notice this would be,
Harvard would have had a field day with this melody if he's Cole Porter had not
done one thing.
He's,
he,
he makes this really rather snappy by the use of this kind of stuff.
We're coming on bom,
Bom,
Bom and uh,
Dun Dun.
What's that?
A good example of syncopation.
Yeah,
it turns on the board up there.
But you're good example of syncopation,
sort of jumping in ahead of time,
cutting off the big,
getting in there ahead of time and throwing off the metrical balance for a very
short period of time.
Uh,
well,
okay,
so that's a,
that's a duplo meter piece.
And what we're trying to do here is just here,
if we've got one strong and one weak B or one strong and too weak beats,
uh,
how do we,
how should we do this?
How are you going to do this?
Well,
I think one thing that's very helpful is for you to start to move,
to move around to sway,
tap your foot.
No,
we can't do this during an exam test.
In here it'd be a little bit annoying,
but we really have to,
we really do have to do this now.
Musicians being a bit more uptight,
oftentimes classical musicians,
uh,
then other more spirited folks have developed this tradition of using conducting
patterns.
Right?
So for Duplo meter,
we just go down,
up,
down,
up is maybe a little shake over to the right,
up,
down,
that kind of thing.
And for triple we do down,
over,
up,
down,
over,
up,
down,
over,
up.
Okay.
So I'm going to start playing in here and you are going to start conducting.
You're going to listen just for a second and then you're going to move and
you're going to move using the conducting pattern.
Okay?
Good.
Now I see some of you out there,
uh,
from like this,
not really participating.
And if I can get up here and think about this,
I'm old.
I sort of think of myself,
a white Anglo Saxon,
Protestant.
I have every reason in the world to be repressed,
right?
So if I could be up here making a fool of myself on a daily basis,
you guys are much younger than I and known for outrageous behavior.
She can certainly get in here and move in the flow and go with the bead here.
So here we go.
Everybody together,
much better.
Okay,
I'm watching.
Good.
Virtually everyone has got the down beat here.
You're not going Yati.
Yati,
Yati.
Yati Yati so there is a sense of downbeat.
There is a sense of downbeat and we'll come back to that in just a moment.
Let's do a triple meter one.
Here we go.
Excellent.
Very good.
Now I'm going know modulator.
Go to a different key.
Can you conduct this?
Okay.
There's a little confusion here,
so let's try to do together.
You Ready?
Your t.
T.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Let this gentleman out here.
It's actually doing it different from what I am doing and what most of you are
doing,
but you know what?
He's doing it correctly.
We're doing it incorrectly.
Your Tki,
dog,
dog.
Wrong here.
We're off.
We're off because our down beats are strong.
Pulses always have to come on the first part of the ball.
This note,
this note,
the first part of the bars card,
the downbeat,
it's the most important thing and are conducting pattern always has to have the
downbeat of the hand in sync with the strongest impulse in the music.
Then the strong,
the downbeat in the music comes with the downward motion of the hand.
So we were getting the team,
oh,
there's the downbeat Dharma,
but we were putting that on two one,
two,
three,
one,
two.
But we don't want that.
We want one bomb at that point.
So what do we have here?
What's happening?
Well,
there's a little bit of music before the downbeat that's called a pickup.
Okay.
So we have a little pickup di Di team.
I was thinking of a diver in the Olympics,
you know,
they go out there,
don't put it off,
they do these little steps just before the spring off of the board,
Dum bum,
bum bum.
But town that bumping up kind of gets you really land in good and hard on that
downbeat.
So the downbeat is very important to us.
Uh,
and we could conclude this by saying that,
uh,
although all music has a Dell beat,
although all music has a downbeat,
not all music starch with the Down Beach,
sometimes when listening to music,
you have to wait,
listen,
listen for awhile.
And your body almost will start to tell you,
tell you,
start to signal to you,
uh,
where the downbeat is.
Is it really your body that will signal this to you?
I doubt it.
It's your brain up here processing all this information.
We talked about the auditory Cortex,
the first section section,
and maybe there are other parts of the brains that are factoring in here as
well.
But how is it that composers send this information to let's say our auditory
cortex here?
How did they do that?
Well,
there are four principal ways that composers signal to us the whereabouts of the
downbeat.
Okay?
So let's review.
Let's focus on that just for a moment,
okay?
Okay.
Way Number One,
way number one,
uh,
that has to do with duration.
Duration notes are simply longer held longer.
That's how we have a sense of where the downbeat is.
Hmm.
Beautiful.
I guess it's a spiritual beautiful.
Uh,
but think about that shortly.
All of those loans,
no,
to come in on the downbeat.
So that's how,
that's how we start to hear that as a downbeat.
And that's how we know to make our hand.
And go down at that point.
So that's one way.
Another way is through accent.
And to exemplify this,
let's turn to some classical music,
the music of Mozart.
So here we have Mozart's 40th symphony,
his famous g minor symphony.
Um,
and let it go ahead and start to play it just to go ahead
maybe a second or two before it pops up at it.
It's going to come up.
Several of you work actually conducting this.
That's great.
Okay.
This happens to be in Dupo meter and that's fine.
I,
that's,
that wasn't the the question here,
but great.
You're hearing that and I'm delighted.
Uh,
what Mozart has done here,
if we could get the score up here of Mozart's music,
we would see that he is just put a little,
uh,
sort of Arrow over top of a wedge over top of each of the downbeat
so that the string player will really accent though.
But the string player would be accenting them anyway.
Why any,
any violinists in here or anybody ever played a string instrument?
What do you always told to do if you're playing a downbeat with an upbeat go,
are you in good shape?
No,
no,
no.
Your teacher would not be happy with that.
You're Boeing has patterns probably backward at that point.
The string players are taught where there's Chellus going this way,
a downbeat or violas and,
and,
and violinists coming down this way,
that the downward motion of the hand or the Polocrosse,
the strong polocrosse should come with the downbeat that's emphasizes the
downbeat.
That's how we know the downbeat.
So,
so far we've had duration and accent.
Mozart is actually writing accent into this.
The third way that we,
that composers signal to us that we pick up almost intuitively the whereabouts
of downbeats is through patterns of accompaniment.
We'll call it range range.
Okay?
So here's a waltz by Ricard Strauss.
Not to be confused,
uh,
you know,
excuse me by Johann Strauss,
not to be confused with Ricard Strauss that we heard last.
And so on.
What important.
Here's the left hand.
That's why we hear a triple pattern there.
We're hearing two week beach and the strong [inaudible] is always in the lower
position here.
So we're getting low,
middle,
or it could be something as we had the other day and the chart,
Schakowsky,
piano concerto
no.
But each time the downbeat seems to be coming in association with that lowest
note.
So range or position,
if you're in the accompanying can oftentimes signal this information to us.
Um,
and finally,
and most important,
these others I think have been pretty straight forward.
These others had been pretty straight forward.
But what,
uh,
has not been straightforward is something that you might listen to many,
many times and not be aware of.
And that is chord changes.
If you know that we have cords in music,
oh,
these building
blocks that support and melody and they have to change for that melody to be
constant all the time.
But where they change oftentimes is on the downbeat.
Most frequently core changes come on the downbeat.
So composers signaled to us in a fourth way.
The down beat by means of core to change.
Now we're going to play just a little bit of Pop music,
not too loud limbic.
Cause this thing is really hyped up.
I'm a bit of Pop music here and by playing this you might think that I think
that I'm hip or with it,
we're going to play some rock and roll.
Do I look hip or with it hopelessly out of touch with popular culture and nobody
knows this better than I and approve this.
I've chosen a piece because there's a little story with it.
Uh,
I,
I like this piece because it does something and I've used it in previous years
and I put it on and I would announce a,
I'm now going to play out of the dark.
It's an album called document,
bike rim and put it on and,
and ram this fine with me.
That's what it says.
Rim.
Uh,
we put dog about two years after I was doing this,
a student came up and said,
oh professor,
right?
It's really not realm.
Oh sorry.
Okay.
So that's,
that's how distant I am from all of this.
But let's listen to a little this.
It's in a straight forward for rock really comes forth,
not so much in twos,
but in four it's a,
so we'll call this a four four and you can kind of beat a four pattern two,
what are you going to be?
The two patterns,
it doesn't really matter.
But notice that your,
whenever the courts are changing,
they're changing on downbeat.
So let's hear a little bit of this and then we'll stop.
So they don't sue us for copyright infringement when we'll go somewhere else and
take another chunk.
Yeah,
it's strange going on.
Hey.
Okay.
So that's all they're doing.
They're,
they're just taking every time they're changing.
You know what?
Every time I say change and eventually you'd be hearing you'd to be saying
change to every time that changing your hand is going down,
your hand is going down.
So core changes,
maybe the most powerful,
powerful,
oh,
all of these aspects of where the down beat is.
Um,
okay.
I had intended to give you just a little bit of a rhythmic quiz,
but let's just do one of these things.
Here's something else we have to do in here.
We have to hear a rhythm and recognize it.
So we have a,
a series of rhythms on the board up there.
Uh,
you can choose the rhythm for excerpt one.
You can choose rhythm a,
which is,
uh,
Duh,
Duh Duh Duh.
Or You could choose rhythm be
dot.
Duh,
Duh.
So I'm about to play a piece.
It's by Chopin.
Which rhythm is in play here?
Which rhythm of my play?
Is it a or is it B?
So
what do you think?
How many think a,
how you think B?
Okay,
so,
uh,
that's,
that's uh,
um,
not too challenging.
We'll be doing some of that.
Then she'll bend is sitting here and he modulating changes.
Key.
What about this is it,
this is a number two.
Is it a or B?
Lovely about it by Chopin.
How long did it take all Chopin to think that up,
do you suppose?
Two seconds.
Three seconds of white hot inspiration.
I'm 64 years old and I haven't had one second of genius in my entire life.
This is really depressing.
It's discouraging.
I soldier on,
but it hasn't come to you are younger and I'm sure that your moment of genius is
out there.
It's really the,
the,
the difference between,
uh,
perseverance in my case and genius,
pure,
unadulterated genius.
In the case of up,
what a beautiful melody.
In any event,
the answer is what?
Uh,
a,
uh,
for two.
Is it a or B?
Okay.
What do you think,
eh?
Yeah,
so that's his rhythm.
Eight.
Yeah.
All right.
We're going to end with one final exercise.
It's a fun piece.
I think it's fun to do.
It's a piece by Maurice Ravel.
Hold Balero.
It's a unique piece reveal.
Maurice Ravel was a French composer writing in the early 20th century.
It's a unique piece because what he does is take some very basic patterns and
simply repeats them over and over and over again for about 14 and a half
minutes,
depending upon the tempo that the conductor is taking the museum.
So let's listen to a little bit of this music.
And I want you maybe as a group to tap with your foot,
your hand,
whatever.
Just the beat as you here,
you don't have to pay any attention to this.
We'll come to this,
um,
in,
in just a moment,
but just tap it will all maybe eventually altogether the beat.
Here we go.
I am.
Most of you are not tapping so everybody start tapping where you think it is.
Okay,
good.
All right,
let's just pause it right there.
Let's just pause it right there.
Gentlemen,
out here in the orange shirt,
I'm going to have you be a conductor.
You are doing really well and you were conducting correctly early morning.
Um,
so good.
Here's what we got.
We got most people don't,
bom,
Bom,
bom.
Some people are going that,
that,
that.
Um,
and in this course we would know how your,
whether you're hearing dupler triple based on some other information.
So don't worry about if you're doing good,
going down that.
Got that.
That's a little bit fast for B.
What you're doing.
There's actually subdividing the beat into two,
but don't worry about that.
That's fine.
You're,
you're doing eighth notes.
The rest of us are doing.
Other people are doing quarter notes.
Okay,
so the beat is Dun Dun,
Dun,
Dun.
Done.
Now what music have we been hearing here?
Uh,
Santana.
Where are you?
Okay,
come on up here.
Take a look at this.
Linda,
come on over here and take a look at this.
We should have rehearsed this in advance.
We did not do this.
These are two ladies that are very experienced singers.
I want you to just stand right up here,
please.
This,
but they have not been forewarned about this.
Take a look at this.
Okay?
Yeah,
we're going to do it together.
Here we go.
You're going to sing that top melody one.
Ready Go.
Ooh.
La La la La la La la La la La la La la La la La la La la La la La la La la.
Okay,
and we're just going to keep you out.
It'll be fine.
And we're just going to keep going in that.
Once you get to the end,
then we're going to repeat.
Okay,
here we go.
To Sing La,
la,
la La la,
la La.
La,
la,
la La,
la La.
Okay,
so you're going to keep going over it over and over like that.
I'm going to be this thing here.
It's just going,
this is the percussion.
Okay.
There is no pitch too is just rhythm.
Up here we have melody and rhythm here we have just rhythm underneath.
We have
bom,
Bom,
bom.
Well we have basically harmony harmony,
but it has a simple rhythm to it.
It's a rhythm with a couple of different patterns.
You students are going to sing this.
Okay,
so here we go.
Everybody together.
Ready?
Sing,
bom,
Bom,
bom.
Okay.
All right,
so here going to go,
the gentleman in the orange shirt,
I hate to do this to you,
but you've got 30 seconds.
Stand up.
You were doing a great job.
Stand up and uh,
if you could,
that's fine.
You can face me.
We'll coordinate it better this way and just conduct this in three.
All start conducting with you and then you take over.
Here we go,
one ready,
go.
Okay,
great.
This is actually terrific.
We're going to take it to Hoboken in Sheboygan.
We're going to play across across the world with this group.
Okay.
Thank you very much ladies.
The point here,
final point,
and then I'll let you go.
This is a melody with rhythm.
This is pure rhythm.
This is a harmony with a very simple rhythm here.
Who is playing the beat?
I asked you to conduct the beat or to tap the beat.
Most people,
everybody was tapping the beat just fine and Dandy,
but no notice up here,
nobody is playing the beat.
There's nobody up here.
It's playing the beat.
The Brain perceives all of this complex information and it processes it and it
extrapolates from it.
It extrapolates from it the beat.
But again,
nobody in music except the bass drum player in the marching band.
Nobody in music ever does anything except,
except just play the beat.
Okay,
so I'll see you starting this evening in sections.